ho ho ho and Merry Christmas everyone
we've got no regular Reuben report today
but I will be reacting to three
Christmas scenes here we
go the are we on schedule one more to go
then it's up to you and you better be
right because it look like this last
one's going to take a miracle it's
Christmas Theo it's the time of Miracles
so be of good cheer and call me when you
hit the last
lock Die Hard is a Christmas movie
people can say what they want there's ho
ho ho there's holiday spirit there's a
Christmas party nakatomi Plaza Bruce
Willis wearing a Christmas uh Santa
Claus hat it is a Christmas movie it's a
top three Christmas movie for me all
right what do we got trade them for a
package of sunshine and ravioli Macaroni
if you want the thing you love you did
it
congratulations world's best cup of
coffee great job everybody
it's great to meet
you come over here
boy yeah you know I don't love will
farell we've had this ongoing thing I I
just don't love the guy you know I get
it it's a funny movie there was a a
diner on the upper west that was the
Three Star Diner which I always thought
was nice of them they weren't like no
we're not going to go with the four
stars you know what I mean like that's
world best cup of coffee this Diner was
like we're not that great you know we're
not that great we're three stars I
appreciate that kind of honesty one more
for you
Kevin Sol come Frank okay Frank
[Music]
Frank
christm
[Applause]
that Uncle everybody hates that Uncle
yeah poor little Kevin
mallister yeah this is what movies were
like back
[Music]
then
Kevin
Kevin what a great movie what a great
movie I saw that in the theater when it
came out I think that was uh I'm gonna
guess was it 92 I was gonna say 95 we
got it 92 geez wow time flies man time
flies merry Christmas
everybody